hi in this video I will talk about urea
cycle and why urea cycle is important
for our body so urea cycle is one of the
most important biochemical pathways in
our body because in our body when
protein is broken down it forms amino
acid and when amino acid is broken down
ammonia is produced and ammonia is
highly soluble in water and our body is
mainly composed of blood which is
actually more than 90 percent water so
ammonia could get solubilized in the
blood and can increase the level of
toxicity that is why our body has to
devise a mechanism by which it can
eliminate the ammonia which is produced
from the amino acid catabolism and urea
cycle is that biosynthetic pathway which
ensures ammonia is eliminated properly
and our body is safe from ammonia
toxicity so the reaction of the urea
cycle is happening in the liver and to
some extent in kidney so here is a liver
and if we zoom into the liver so you can
see there are global hepatic lobules
hexagonal hepatic lobules composed of
hepatocytes parasites our liver cells so
if we zoom this is the Heaviside one
hepatocyte one liver cell so all the
reactions of the urea cycle is taking
place in the mitochondria and the
cytosol some portion of the reactions
are in the mitochondria and some portion
of the reactions are taking place in the
cytosol so let's just zoom into the
mitochondria and see the reactions in
step by step so here we have the
mitochondria of the hepatocyte
so what happens all the amino acids
which are broken down are actually
funneled in form of government by the
reaction transamination they are usually
formed glutamate they are usually formed
glutamate and glutamate would ultimately
get converted
into ammonium ammonium ion and on the
other hand side glutamine which entered
the mitochondria can be converted into
pyramid by Goethe - mitochondrial enzyme
who dominates so the first step of the
urea cycle is coming combined
combination of bicarbonate and ammonium
ion and this is triggered by carbamoyl
phosphate synthetase or CPS one enzyme
which ultimately forms the first product
which is carbamoyl phosphate and now the
only thing which is present in the
mitochondria is actually combining with
carbamoyl phosphate forms citrulline and
citrulline would leave mitochondria in
the cytosol citrulline would form
Citronelle Amb intermediate with the ATP
present in the cytosol then aspartate
would get combined with citronella MP
and it would form a spurted RG no
succinate now from aspartate our gino
succinate arginine would be produced and
fumarate would be released
now this arginine would regenerate
anything so in this cycle i'm skipping
all the details of the enzymes but i
have mentioned the rate-limiting enzyme
which is carbamoyl phosphate synthetase
so arginine would be ultimately
converted into only thing and only thing
would again again perform this cycle by
converted by getting converted into
citrulline and the whole cycle would be
repeated so from arginine to onething
conversion step as a by-product urea is
formed and urea is the less harmful than
ammonia so we started with ammonium ion
and we ended up with urea and urea is
excreted by urine so this is how harmful
ammonia is actually excreted out by your
area but by the urine as a form of
yuria so that is why we are Yuriko
tillich so excretion product of human is
you yeah so here is the regulation of
hylia cycle so there are two fold
regulation one is genetic regulation
another is allosteric regulation so
genetic regulation includes expression
of the urea cycle enzymes people that
taking that are taking a diet full of
protein have a greater expression of
urea cycle enzymes however in the
starving condition the carbon cane
skeleton of glucose genic amino acids
are broken down in order to form energy
and side by side ammonia level increase
in order to decrease that ammonia level
urea cycle enzymes are overexpressed in
this situation allosteric regulation
involves regulation of CP s 1 that means
carbamoyl phosphate synthetase 1 which
is illustrated by in as it a glutamate n
acetyl glutamate would actually
positively regulate the urea cycle and
on the other hand side ms aytul
glutamate is produced from Karamat and
acetyl co a an arginine is acting as a
positive regulator of in acetabulum it
synthetase which is actually forming an
asset algorithm it this is how arginine
and in acetabulum it is positively
regulating the reactions of urea cycle I
hope you enjoyed the video if you like
my video please like and then subscribe
thank you